hallo mein name ist luca mich gehört den
super heroes in you later ich weiß nicht
was mich erwartet ich habe dieses spiel
irgendwo mülleimer gefunden neben an
einer seitenstraße hat mir gedacht ich
spiels mal oh mein gott ach du heilige
scheiße die schüssel wir sollen space
drücken um zu wada
wir sind der beste superman aller zeiten
okay ich kann mich hier um gucken wenn
ich die maus drehe wie bei jedem spiel
geht die maus einfach so aus dem bild ra
fuß ist nicht nur noch via sd benutzen
dann
wow das ist einfach der beste superman
aller zeiten wir können tatsächlich mit
dem
das erinnert mich tatsächlich anders
glitches game ever was ich vor
das ist das problem an habe ich das
video hochgeladen ich verlinke euch das
spiel was ich meine hier könnt ihr euch
das anschauen das war genau so behindert
way anschauen
seit ich dann versuchen wir natürlich
mal hier die werten bürger der stadt zu
retten komm lieber vorwärts
tatsächlich komme ich gerade nicht
vorwärts oh mein gott bin ich hoch
trotzdem bin ich immer noch auf der
gleichen stelle
cool ich bin exakt vier meter zurück
gewandert ich glaube das spiel ist
gerade
was ist das ich habe das spiel neu
geladen und wird da oh mein gott da ist
eine person die müssen wir retten
gleiche drücken space und das ganze zu
starten
ich verstehe das nicht ich kann mich
nicht mal bewegen das einzige was ich
drücken kann es space mehr geht hier
tatsächlich nicht ich bin super
ich drücke jetzt tatsächlich gerade mal
alle tasten durch
was macht er denn damit seinem kopf von
ich habe das gefühl wir kommen langsam
vorwärts
wir springen eigentlich einfach nur hoch
wenn man so guckt denkt man immer dass
ich nach vorne fliege aber ich bin immer
noch auf der gleichen stelle
es muss doch irgendeine fucking
möglichkeit geben dass ich in diese
verdammte stadt komme er kann doch nicht
sein dass das ganze spiel darauf besteht
dass man nur space drücken muss kommen
wenn ich so komplett nach unten gucken
sie zu auf das will ich gleich volle den
gebäuden reihen fallen aber wenn ich mir
jetzt fallen lasse
neulich fall halt gerade mal irgendwie
gar nicht schaffen sich die stadt wie
schaffen sie schauen sich die stadt
geschaffen ich habe sie nicht ermittelt
wir sind schon mal näher an der stadt
ran da hinten ist der mann auf dem boden
wie retten müssen und wir sind hier in
der luft
tschuldigung für den upload dieses
spiels ok nachdem wir jetzt ca 4000
kreise in der luft gedreht haben
wir haben fünf meter geschafft wenn wir
schon nicht mitfliegen schaffen können
dann versuchen wir es wenigstens mit dem
robben
oh mein gott freunde schaffen wir es
schaffen wir es schaffen wir sie
tatsächlich gerade so als würden wir
schaffen den typen button sogar einen
doppel bist du diese
ich gehe uns jetzt einen letzten versuch
irgendwie in die stadt zu kommen fragt
mich nicht wie ich das mache den typen
zu steuern
das weiß ich selber nicht
in diesem gebäude da mein tag besteht
daraus einer wand so schön macht mega
viel das sieht komplett falsch aus
gerade ich komme mir gerade nicht weg
ich bin gefangen bäume wir haben die
chance wir können ihn retten wir können
ihn retten wir können es schaffen wir
können es schaffen wenn keine chance
hat sich das wasser geradezu gras
verband lied ich bin hier um mich zu
retten alter mann ich rette dich ich
hätte dich rettet ich vertrauen kann man
hier kommt zu mir ich hätte dich
muss ich dazu noch irgendwas sagen hey
hey du ich beende an dieser stelle das
video ja